you know the last time we sat down with
Kim she just completed rehab following
her arrest out of Beverly Hills hotel
since then she's been arrested again for
shoplifting and had to deal with the
death of her best friend and ex-husband
Monty now the former Beverly Hills
housewife is about to make her debut on
another high-intensity reality show
here's the big question can she stay
sober I asked her about it walking into
it was not what I expected was there
because some concern being in that kind
of environment as you are dealing with
your sobriety and all of a sudden you're
cast in an environment where people are
drinking and that there's madness going
wasn't tempting for me in any way if
anything but you see something like that
you almost go like whoo thank God it's
not me it's why
Kim's repeating the reality TV cycle of
madness and she's even bringing her
daughter Kimberly into it on lifetimes
the mother-daughter experiment celebrity
edition but Kim's nemesis this time
isn't sister Kyle or ISA Rinna it's
Heidi Montag you shoved Heidi though
sterling how are you gonna stop from
being pushed to that I didn't say I was
you know telling that I'm not gonna go
like right now Kim's in recovery and
goes to weekly meetings she's trying to
heal but it's very clear she's still raw
from the pain of losing her ex-husband
and best friend Bonnie Brinson he was
glad he was going first cuz he didn't
think he could bear if it were me and
then he had to be left here Bonnie what
was your final words with Monty I said I
love you and then I felt him just kind
of leave and I was shocking I just I
didn't expect it I really got old of you
mm-hmm right there oh yeah how did that
affect you and how how did it affect
your life your sobriety
last time you had say a drink I'll just
say that my recovery is going amazing it
really is after nearly a year Kim
returns to the Real Housewives tonight
to face off with Kyle but I used our
exclusive sit-down to clear up some
rumors there had even been speculation
that you were at one point homeless what
was that about
and living you know in a $400 a night
you know hotel in Santa Monica
overlooking the beach and people are
like she's homeless so you know it's
hardly homeless and while drunken cat
fights and a mug shot are the images of
Kim everyone knows we all hope her tough
journey will turn they'd have a happier
ending I've told you today more than I
probably tell anybody ever again this is
the last time I'll discuss my recovery
publicly because I want to get it one
last time out there to people to know
I'm in recovery and it's mine and it's
nobody's business what do you think I
want a believer yeah it seems like the
car is headed in the right direction she
just got to keep it on the road but we
are definitely rooting for Kim
Riley certainly wish her the best
you